okay thank you very much my name is
Samir chef it's a pleasure for me to
tell you about our study which is a nice
brain initiative funded study in the
u-ace 3 category our title is as you can
see here deep brain stimulation for
depression using direct directional
current steering and individualized
network targeting I wanted to start off
by acknowledging my kopi eyes native
protein and wayne goodman who are also
in to give presentations on this topic
and this slide just shows our group
overall so we have two clinical sites
Baylor with myself and Wayne Goodman as
a COPI eyes here along with
collaborators Sanjay Matthew and kelipah
Genki and then UCLA with Cokie I Nader
brought in and then also our
investigators - Randall Espinosa
Catherine R and Anthea Susannah this is
a heavily engineering involved and so we
have a great team at Brown University
led by Dave Wharton and then our other
collaborators as well as our industry
partner at Boston Scientific so just as
a bit of historical context I'll start
by just describing the current state of
affairs as a you know recently based on
previous trials of DBS for depression
over the past several years to provide a
background for what motivated our study
and why we design it the way that we did
so DBS for depression has been around
for for some time it was initially
motivated in the ventral capsule ventral
striatum target based on the work of DBS
for OCD in this target and this is the
ventral portion of the answer limb of
the internal capsule that's the target
which initially was targeted for
capsulotomy procedures lesion procedures
that were developed really in the mid
part of the last century and from then
on so DBS for OCD developed in this
target and then based on the improvement
in mood seen in those patients DBS for
depression was tried in this target as
well so this is one of the important
initial studies that were multi-site
with 15 patients at Combe Clinic Brown
and MGH and
in 15 patients and this was done as an
open-label series targeting that metro
capsule of ventral striatum region with
bilateral DBS electrodes and as you can
see here the responder rate was 40% of
six months and a little over half at
their longest follow-up and response is
defined as a 50% reduction in the
symptoms score the Hamilton or the
Montgomery aspart scales and even some
of these patients achieve remission
which is a score of less than ten on
those scales at 40% at the last
follow-up and of course these are
patients who are refractory to
conventional treatments medications
behavioral therapy and even oftentimes
electroconvulsive therapy so this
response rate is quite remarkable
adverse events why is the most important
thing to know was that there there can
be hypomania induced by stimulation this
target that initial study and and ones
like it led to industry-sponsored trial
of DBS and this target called the
reclaim trial and this was a dublin sham
controlled trial where patients were
randomized to sham versus active
stimulation one month after the surgery
and unfortunately this one did not have
a very positive result at the interim
analysis so there are 280 patients
planned when 30 were operated and ads
and follow-up they broke the blinds look
at the data and the sham rate was 14%
but the active ring was also only 20%
which was a non significant difference
so the sponsor makes we stop this trial
at that point because they were not
optimistic about its prospects for
success excuse me the other important
target to discuss it's very relevant to
this study is the sub genuine cingulate
so this is also known as area 25 this is
sub general portion of a single at gyrus
and regions nearby and this is really
the work of the group initially from
Toronto and then also Emory initially a
Helen a burg Hunter's Lozano at a
Toronto and then dr. main Berg
continuing this at the Emory group and
so there were some
several initial trials and then there
were a few subsequent trials and the two
that I've shown you here are just
examples of the variability that can be
seen in the open label studies of this
target this the first one Holtz himer at
all at 2012 is the Emory group the 92
excuse me 92 percent response rate on
the other hand the Canadian multicenter
trial published the same year at 29
percent response rate so quite a
variability but there was enough
optimism to where again another industry
supported trial called the broadened
trial was launched based on the
preliminary results for this target
again 201 patients planned and again the
line was broken at 90 at a plan in from
analysis to see whether there was much
divergence between sham and active trial
design was similar in terms of having
randomization to active versus sham just
a month after surgery and again a sham
rate of about 17 percent which is as
expected but again an active of only 20%
and so if utility analysis demonstrated
a 17 percent chance of seeing divergence
between those groups if the trial were
continued and so again based on these
data the sponsor decided to stop the
trial the openly will follow-up did
demonstrate some improvement as you can
see there about 50 percent response rate
a year and a half to two years
afterwards in the in the open leawo
follow-up but again you know this trial
sermon did not meet its end point and
was stopped at that interim point so
this is kind of the point at which we
were really deciding what to do next
regarding DBS for depression and so you
know based on the promising preliminary
data but then the two large sham
controlled randomized trials that did
not show an active response being
greater than sham we were trying to
decide what to do next and so based on
this you know we had the questions about
what the path would be going forward and
after a lot of consideration we thought
about the following ideas one is that
you know there's really a in importance
that we put on deriving a network-based
understanding of depression certainly
specifically but also mental health
disorders in general the idea is that
these mental health disorders or
psychiatrist or ters like neurological
disorders for example are disorders of a
brain network and not just a single spot
in the brain in particular with major
depressive disorder the symptom based
classification that we use for this is
fairly limiting there are there nine
criteria in the DSM and the patient
needs to demonstrate five out of these
nine criteria to be considered as having
major depressive disorder so you can
have two patients with only one
overlapping criterion of the same
diagnosis and anybody who's seen
patients with this disorder they can
look very different and so it's
reasonable to conjecture that patients
who are looking different you know
typically symptomatically that this
difference is because perhaps of
differences in the brain networks
underlying these disorders and therefore
in the manifestation of these
differences in the underlying networks
and so the proposition would be to take
an approach like the RDoc approach
promulgated by the nih which is this
idea of trying to orthogonalize these
disorders on two axes of neural circuit
dysfunction as opposed to symptom
clusters and by doing so this may
provide a more rational testament basis
for therapeutic intervention so if we
think a little more about number of
disorders and and networks in general
these are just a couple examples of
resting state fMRI studies done over the
years which just promote the idea that
the brain is not just one homogeneous
blob of activity but rather that there
are areas that specialize and segregate
and then Co activate and work together
when they're doing certain things and
this could be at rest this could be
during activity but the idea is that
there are regions of the brain that work
together to accomplish certain behaviors
and work together to forge a label you
regulate certain emotions there's some
nice work that's been done by a number
of different groups this is an example
of the Stanford group that is talking
about Psychiatry using this network
based approach this study is one of a
proposition for a neural circuit
taxonomy so it's known through resting
state fMRI studies that there are
different networks in the brain for
example in blue the default mode Network
these are regions of the brain that tend
to be more active when a patient is for
example just to rest and not engage in
any particular activity others for
example that are engaged at the salience
network when there is a salient stimulus
or when attention needs to be applied to
a certain stimulus or in the purple for
example the positive effect Network
these are areas of the brain that seem
to engage when there's rewarding
stimulus or whether it was a evaluation
of reward so it could be that these
types of different networks underlie
different regulation of affect mood and
cognition and perhaps dysfunction within
these networks can differentially
manifest in different subtypes of
depression and indeed there's a you know
potential there's a proposition within
this paper for example where bio type
one has shown there that the ruminative
type of depression is perhaps housed in
or contained within the default mode
network is in those parts of the brain
in the default mode maybe especially
responsible for that type of depression
the rumination type or for example the
the positive effects circuit this
regulation of that circuit could lead to
an hedonic types of depression as
exemplified there in this bio type 5 so
again it could be the dysfunction within
these different networks manifests as
different types of depression and
importantly there for patients who have
these different types of depression have
differential contribution from these
different networks and different brain
regions so in the question that we're
trying to address here is how do we
apply this approach of this network
based understanding of mood and
cognitive regulation to
to depression and DBS for depression so
to do this we borrowed from another
field that thinks about network based
circuits quite a lot and that is in the
field of epilepsy so patients with
epilepsy who are medically refractory
are potentially surgical candidates if
we can identify where the seizures are
coming from we may be able to take out
or somehow modulate that area to stop
their seizures very commonly if we can't
figure out where the seizures are coming
from based on non-invasive studies
imaging for example or scalp EEG then
oftentimes we will need to actually
implant intracranial electrodes these
are probes that go within the brain this
is an example of what an intracranial
investigation may look like so these
these probes are placed in the operating
room for example as shown here and then
once they're placed in the operating
room the patient then stays in the
hospital in the Epilepsy Monitoring Unit
for several days while we allow them to
have seizures and when they have a
seizure is now with the probes directly
in the brain we can tell exactly where
these seizures are starting and then
create a surgical plan so we can apply
this approach of intracranial recordings
to understand the neural circuits in the
brain which is used very commonly in
epilepsy but is used hardly at all
outside of epilepsy we can apply this to
our idea of depression in the network
basis and depression so we can for
example try to orthogonalize this idea
of depression on to these different
let's call them symptom domains or
dysfunctional domains the positive
effect domain the negative effect domain
the cognitive control domain and again
these are borrowed from our doc
formalization each one of these domains
has different symptom clusters
associated with it and therefore other
categories of dysfunctional systems
associated with these domains so for
example the positive effect domain may
consist of symptoms of Anton dona
psychomotor retardation and it may
result from dysfunction in reward
processing an action initiating systems
and again these systems can map on to
different brain networks
based on information again that we have
from a lot of good imaging and
electrophysiology work we can try to
engage these different networks using an
interventional procedures like deep
brain stimulation so now the table on
the left here shows in the far left
column different brain regions that we
think are involved in the various
different symptom domains or constructs
shown in those middle columns so for
example the ventral medial PFC the MIL
ofc the dorsal ACC etc are
differentially involved in these
different domains and constructs example
the positive and negative valence
Network and the cognitive control
Network shown by those X's and then
critically those different gray matter
regions can be accessed via different
white matter hubs in particular the vcvs
and the sub channel siculus so that's
shown in the final two columns we really
think of these two areas as as hubs and
not necessarily as targets in and of
themselves but rather hubs within
networks that we can use to access the
rest of the broader network again shown
in those gray matter areas in the left
column and of course you'll notice that
the BCBS and the subjective singlet of
course are the two targets that I
mentioned the beginning in terms of
having some interesting data from
previous studies so our approach here
really is to implant DBS electrodes
within those two important target hubs
the BCBS and sub channel cingulate we're
using a DBS system that has segmented
electrodes as shown here on the left and
therefore the stimulation field model or
the volume of tissue that's activated
can be directionally tuned so that we
can kind of push the stimulation
direction in in an arbitrary direction
around the the axis of that electrode
and then sort of the right here are you
know is a diffusion tensor imaging
analysis of a single patient with an
electrode in one spot but we can engage
for sub-networks because we can use the
directionality the system to push the
stimulation one direction versus the
other and therefore with an implanted
electrode without moving it we can
engage different regions in the network
just using this directional capability
so our final plan here our approach
really is shown here which is where we
implant a patient with DBS leads that's
shown in red and that's targeting both
of these white matter hub targets the
sub danuel singlet and the vcvs again
showing red and that's two electrodes
per hemisphere for a total of four
stimulating DBS leads and also with
these temporary stereo EEG monitoring
electrodes as shown in blue this is the
application borrowed from the epilepsy
experience where we do this all the time
as a mission before so the patient is
implanted with these temporary SCT
monitoring electrodes targeting these
usual suspects regions of grey matter
the DL PFC vmPFC ACC ofc medial temporal
region etc so the patients are implanted
with this full system and then we study
the system and just a note in terms of
how we actually plan this implant
there's a video that's about to play
here which will show you the system that
we're using which is in collaboration
with some another collaborative Cameron
McIntyre is at Case Western who has
developed the system using a augmented
reality system for visualizing all of
the tracks that are connecting the
stimulating electrodes to the temporary
monitoring electrodes because you can
imagine it's a very complicated surgical
plan to think in three dimensions
regarding all the different electrodes
that are being placed in the connections
between them and so this video will show
you know just example of how we do the
planning using this 3d holographic
augmented reality system as a play video
here
it's also good that processing massive
amounts of
okay so then just continue on with the
the approach for the for these patients
so this shows the full five years
timeline of the project and in year two
is that we started planting the patients
and each one of those patients is shown
by that little a purple + green bar and
the little blow-up shows the expansion
of that purple region so the patient is
implanted kind of you know day zero
after their workup and I should mention
of course these are patients with severe
and treatment-resistant depression that
have failed the the standard medication
therapy behavioral therapy in electric
Molson therapy at a minimum and they've
been evaluated thoroughly by our
psychiatry coop so these patients after
the appropriate preoperative procedures
and counseling consent are enrolled in
the study they're implanted on day zero
with the electron configuration I showed
you a couple of slides ago with the
perhaps here to stimulating electrodes
and 5s EEG monitoring electrodes they're
there then caps in the hospital in the
EMU for a period of 10 days where we do
a series of recording and stimulation
experiments to understand their varying
depression Network on an individual
basis so the idea is that by the end of
those 10 days we were very thorough
understanding of their networks as they
relate to modulation of affect and
emotion and cognition at the end of the
ten days the temporary electrodes are
explanted the DBS stimulate electrodes
are internalized permanently - excuse me
pulse generators and then they go on and
have a year-and-a-half trial with an
open-label optimization phase followed
by a blinded discontinuation phase that
is sham controlled to get at questions
of efficacy
so that's the design of the study and
overall the the idea is that we're
trying to figure out this complex
problem which is that in general in DBS
we have these input parameters which we
adjust which are showing your frequency
pulse width etc and then we have some
behavior which in the case of depression
is you know mood and other thing is that
the patient reports and can be measured
but maybe crudely but we don't know the
complex transformation that occurs
between these input parameters in this
output behavior we're trying to
essentially understand this intermediate
step of this network state which
consists of the electrographic response
of the brain network and circuits to our
stimulation and by understanding this
individual individualized and
intermediate the network state we can
better understand the circuits and
therefore better understand how the
stimulation is is actually engaging
these circuits and influencing behavior
and hopefully with this approach we'll
really be able to individually tailor
stimulation to each patient and move the
needle on DBS for depression so I really
like to thank the NIH for the funding
and thank my collaborators the co P eyes
and co-investigators on the study and
thank you very much for attention thanks
Samir for the introduction to this talk
I've Nader parati and I am a professor
and vice chair of academic affairs at
UCLA in the department of neurosurgery
you're gonna continue this talk
reviewing our concept of network
targeting and engagement as it pertains
to developing a therapy of the brain
stimulation for treatment-resistant
depression I'll start with my
disclosures I work with multiple
companies in the north technology space
including most relevant Boston
Scientific who is a collaborator on this
project and as you've heard our work is
collaborative between a sameer chef
myself and wing Goodman who you'll hear
from after me on this NIH funded grant
through the brain initiative this is our
overall team and I think it's important
to highlight the
is a multidisciplinary team across
multiple institutions with different
areas of expertise you've heard from
Samir who has extensive knowledge and
familiarity with the neurosurgery of
applications of psychiatric
neuromodulation and of course Wayne who
you'll hear from has extensive
experience on the psychiatric side and
the management and stimulation
programming of these devices and I
joined the team with a specific focus on
the neurosurgical aspects but also
imaging and target engagement this
really is a tour de force with input
from neurosurgery psychiatry imaging and
neuroscience extensive engineering and
multiple other teams as you'll see
throughout this presentation and the
subsequent presentation so I think it's
important to build off of what we've
heard from Sameer but we've had multiple
failures of neuromodulation trials and
we can hypothesize about why the studies
occurred there could be heterogeneous
populations and so we need methods to
improve patient selection it could be
because of impress imprecise targeting
we don't quite know where to put our
electrodes and where to turn on the
stimulation location is everything in a
targeted neuromodulation so we need
methods to improve our targeting and
finally we don't really know too much
about stimulation paradigms we need to
better understand the physiology of what
we do of the disease and the therapeutic
interventions and so what I want to
focus on in this part of the talk is
really our hypothesis that many of the
failures in neuro modulation
particularly for psychiatric
applications is due to inefficient
network engagement so to build on that I
want to talk about why we focus on
connectivity and there's multiple lines
of evidence that lead us to focus on how
the brain is connected one is an area of
the human connectome we know that
disease diseases affect networks we
know that depression in particular
involves multiple nodes throughout the
brain and aberrant communication between
those areas of the brain we also know
that there are very rich connections in
the brain particularly in the frontal
lobe which is relevant to treatment
resistant depression and so if we're
going to understand the disease and its
networks and these rich connections we
need to figure out how that applies to
both our disease in our therapy the next
thing is that we know that DBS or deep
brain stimulation modulates networks you
know for a long time the field was
focused on what the brain stimulation
does at the target nucleus but now we
know that stimulating deep inside the
brain actually has widespread effects
throughout the brain and so we need to
understand these networks and how to
engage the right network with the right
stimulation paradigm
finally this emphasizing the employ the
point of networks
we know that the invasive type of
stimulation that we do is very much
related in terms of functional brain
networks the non-invasive stimulation
such as transcranial magnetic
stimulation so multiple lines of
evidence point to the importance of
networks both for a disease
pathophysiology but also our therapeutic
mechanisms and so when we bring those
together we arrive at this idea that we
need to focus on network engagement in
our therapy development we want to take
that one step further because we're not
just interested in different parts of
the brain and how they're connected but
how they are functionally connected I
want to draw an analogy to an area
that's very well understood and very
well accepted which is cardiac disease
you know if you have an abnormality in
your heart you get a cardiac arrhythmia
when we place a cardiac pacemaker no one
questions their cardiologist if they're
told that they need a cardiac pacemaker
and so we would posit that the brain is
very similar in that if there's a
disease in a brain network that actually
causes a brain arrhythmia and if we're
able to put the pacemaker in the right
spot in the brain we can engage those
networks and restore a more normal
rhythm and so that's the approach that
we
take in the philosophy that we have in
progressing along this idea of engaging
brain networks one final comment before
I get into a few examples is that
connectivity can be defined in many
different ways and before we get into
surgery before we plan our surgery we
can do that with non-invasive methods
particularly diffusion tractography but
there's also functional methods which
includes deep brain recordings of local
field potentials or even spiking
activity and so what we want to do is
understand the relationship between all
of these different types of connectivity
both in disease and in therapy and
ultimately deliver a very informed and
rationalized
approach to deep brain stimulation
rather than just putting an electrode
somewhere and hoping that it's going to
work I want to focus on imaging first
and then I'll move on to neurophysiology
you know our field of stereotactic
neurosurgery has really been a field
that's been enabled by a technology of
precision but more importantly brain
imaging and mapping if we go way back we
were a field that used in direct
targeting pneumo encephalography just
looking at patterns of air in the brain
then we had a real advance when we had
MRI to see the structure so we can
target nuclei so such as the sub salami
base and much work has been put into
optimizing those sequences but I think
we're moving into the next area which is
network based targeting rather than
structural targeting and so our work
built on therapies that we know we that
are effective and so I'm going to focus
briefly on targeted neuromodulation in
the thalamus for tremor
and it's a really good model not because
particularly we need to improve our
therapies for tremor but if we
understand how it applies to how network
based targeting can apply to a therapy
that we know works then we can extend it
to new diseases so in this case this is
using a focus ultrasound fellow monami
we can see in the middle panel labeled D
a bright yellow spot which is the area
that has the highest pattern or high
probability connectivity with precentral
gyrus
and on the left side of the figure you
can see the focused ultrasound Kalamata
me or the area of the brain that's been
burned for tremor and as you slowly
shift to the right you can see the
overlap between those two and what I
could show you here are ROC curves and
in particularly what we see is that when
there is a high concordance between that
area of the thalamus with the highest
connectivity to the precentral gyrus and
the lesion that is created by focus
ultrasound a lobotomy we get a very good
response or a high probability of a good
tremor control so this shows in practice
the theoretical benefits of targeted
neuromodulation based on networks so I'm
going to shift over to the psych
psychiatric side and treatment resistant
depression the area of the subjuntivo
cingulate is the first area of focus on
and it's been an area that has been of
interest since suggested by Helen
neighbor several years ago as a central
node in controlling or modulating a
depression but we didn't know very much
about it and there's some initial
anatomic studies that showed that
responders and non-responders seem to be
generally targeted in the same area so
structure seemed not to be enough and
there was a suggestion that we could
rely on tractography or the connectivity
of that area and again by Helen Mae Berg
amputee or even passe developed early
evidence that if you were if the Electra
was in a spot that seemed to have
connectivity to multiple areas as
illustrated in the top right image then
you get a good response but this can be
very challenging to use in real time you
know it's a search and confirm method
rather than giving an actual target and
so our group work to develop patient
specific tractography and what we call a
tractography optimized target meaning
that we start with a general area the
subject was seeing it at the entire area
where everyone seems to get electrodes
and look at the connectivity pattern
that emerges from there in each
specification
and in particular we're interested in
projections that goes to the anterior
cingulate region the medial prefrontal
cortex the ventral striatum through the
unsent fasciculus and through a series
of recursive probability analyses we
could find the one spot which we call
the checked ography optimized target
that has the highest probability of
connectivity with all of the regions of
the sub general cingulate projects - and
in fact if we look on the right side of
the image with the red yellow heat map
and if we look at the tract ography
across a large cohort of patients from
that single voxel that is the
tractography optimized target you can
see that we get projections to all of
those key areas again the answer is
single as the medial prefrontal cortex
ventral striatum and down through the
exit fasciculus towards the amygdala and
so we believe that if we use this
methodology and we place our electrodes
at that area that tractography optimized
target which is very definable in a
tomographic space then we can get better
outcomes for our patients and so we
looked at this in a stack a series of
two subjects we defined this
tractography optimized target which is
realist rated here and all the different
regions on the top right image you can
see a differential pattern of highest
positive connectivity with different
areas of the brain on the bottom-left
pattern sorry the bottom left panel we
see in yellow the single voxel is the
highest probability of connectivity with
all of those targets and the bottom
right is probably the most important
figure and what it shows in red for both
subjects there's a subject on top and a
subject on bottom is the pattern of
connectivity of that tractography
optimized target and it shows
connectivity to all those areas of
interest on the other hand if we look in
blue that is the connectivity of the
area that was stimulated in that subject
and you can see that the area that was
stimulated in the top panel does not
have projections down into the ventral
striatum or through the lungs of
fasciculus
whereas the person who did respond did
have that pattern of connectivity and if
we look at how close the area of
stimulation was to that
I thought reveals my target in fact the
responder was much closer to that target
than the non-responders so we have some
real human confirmation that this
chatlog Rafi optimized target is
important and in fact it's what we are
using in our trial as we develop this
therapy for depression even further just
to show you why this is important to
look at on an individual basis and here
are some data from a hundred patients
the hundred pages one hundred centers so
the human connectome project and we
looked at the differential probability
of connectivity to different areas so
I'll just take you through the top row
but you can look through this at your
leisure at the second and subsequent
rows the top row focuses on connectivity
to the uncinate fasciculus but we also
have ventral strain and below that
enters cingulate cortex medial
prefrontal cortex on the right and then
the left but on the top row what we see
is an area in the sub general cingulate
that in most patients has a high
positive connectivity with the uncinate
fasciculus and it tends to be on that
first column in the pit on the sagittal
view posterior within the sub general
cingulate region on the axial images it
seems to be more lateral and but more
importantly than that area of suggesting
is that is most commonly connected you
see that there's variability across
subjects so it's not that every single
patient has a very constant pattern of
connectivity within the sub disease
cingulate there is an overall pattern
but there's a lot of interest subject
variability and that's why having these
patient specific tracks order the
optimized targets we feel is going to be
essential on the right panel we see that
integrated map of where the tractography
optimized target is and again I want to
emphasize that while there are areas
that seem to be hotter particularly you
can see in that axial image where it's
lighter green and but there's a
distribution as well so it's not
constant across every single subject and
that lack of consistency is really what
we think contributes to that
heterogeneity in clinical trials and the
failure of some clinical trials
so that's the subjective thing that
we've also done this in the ventral
capsule ventral striatum target and this
is something of a work more in progress
but we use the very similar approach and
we looked at the overall area the
different areas that people targeted in
the ventral capsule ventral striatum
primarily for obsessive-compulsive
disorder but looked at where it connects
to and there are connections to the
nucleus accumbens to the amygdala the
dorsal lateral prefrontal cortex the
lateral / frontal cortex and a medial
orbitofrontal cortex and we again do
this recursive process of looking at
what which voxels within the general
area of interest has the highest
probability of connectivity to each of
these regions and then we can create
what we call the vcvs tot t OT it should
be which is the tractography optimized
target that has the highest positive
connectivity with all the different
regions that this area projects to and
in this particular subject if we look at
in that second row you see it in light
blue in yellow what you see are
stimulation field maps from a patient
who was implanted with DBS for OCD and
really what I want to highlight is the
overlap between our tractography
optimize target and the stimulation
field map showing very good concordance
in this person who happens to be a good
responder to the therapy we see the same
pattern in this next subject or example
subject where the try therapy optimize
target is shown in light blue in the
first and second row yellow and the
third row shows of stimulation field map
if we look at the bottom row the green
area show a high area of concordance
between this tractography optimize
target our stimulation field mapping in
patients who experience benefit from
deep brain stimulation so again we have
a tractography or network guided area
that we can target for potential therapy
the last thing I want to highlight
interpret right ography
is that in fact it helps us identify
differences between our targets
and what we see here are the projections
from the subjective cingulate which is
shown in red as well as the ventral
Castle ventral striatum both of which we
know projects of prefrontal cortices but
when we look at the two together we can
very clearly see different patterns of
connectivity's of prefrontal cortex in
this example you see the prefrontal
projection of the ventral capsul ventral
striatum really wrapping around the
projections of the subject in a
cingulate and this is important for the
next part of our study that I'm about to
tell you about because it tells us where
we need to record from when we're
interested in these networks in
developing our therapy it gives us
patient specific targets to put our
recording electrodes in in order to
really understand the networks related
to disease as well as our therapies so I
want to transition briefly to the neuro
physiological side of network engagement
and show you an example again from our
work in the thalamus
but in during deep brain stimulation
surgery we're putting electrodes deep in
the thalamus but we're also putting an
ACOG strip as shown and on the top left
panel labeled B an e-card strip over the
cortex and what we're looking for on the
bottom left is the tracts that connects
at the thalamic target with the cortical
target in fact we were able to identify
the cortical region of recording that's
connected to our syllabic area and on
the top right although it's small what
you'll see is that there's very specific
patterns of coherence or coupling of
oscillatory activity between the
thalamus and cortex and it's very
spatially specific and we can show that
there's not only coherence or coupling
but there's what we call them
thalamocortical phase amplitude coupling
between the thalamus and cortex that
again is very spatially specific and
it's modulated activity so this is
important because it shows us that these
structural connections are not just
structural connections but we can
actually use it to target our functional
recordings and so it takes us to the
final step which is this slide that
illustrates a clinical trial that we're
about to undertake in which we are going
to target our deep brain stimulation
electrodes based on our tractography
they
some those tractography optimized
targets but we're also going to put
recording electrodes in the areas that
we believe those times those deep brain
stimulation targets are projecting to so
within the medial prefrontal cortex
within the orbital frontal cortex in the
amygdala as well as an anterior
cingulate region and so we are now
making a complete loop between
image-guided
Network engagement as well as
physiological network monitoring and we
will have these patients in the hospital
for 10 days recording from their brains
while they perform a specific behavioral
task while we activate the electrodes to
actually confirm neuromodulation of
these different distant regions within
the network and eventually put all these
together synthesize these to develop
patient specific patterns of stimulation
to treat the underlying diagnosis of
treatment resistant depression so in
conclusion I think the area of just
tried an invasive their modulation is
really behind us we need to have a much
more informed approach and we would
posit that it's this Network guided
modulation that is critical and we can
look at the networks but with imaging as
well as with neurophysiology I think we
can it should be targeting engaging and
recording from disease and symptom
related networks and the idea that I
think is really important is that these
concepts of network engagement really
weak we can learn from one disease and
apply it to other diseases as I've shown
here both in imaging in neurophysiology
that we have extended what we've learned
in the thalamocortical relationships to
networks that are specific to treatment
related depression or trip treatment
resistant depression with that I'd like
to conclude and acknowledge Ebisu Lackey
who's done the vast majority of the
imaging work here that I shared as well
as Suresh Niko Thurid who is listed
right below her who did much of the
fillet awkward that you've seen here
and then we've got an extensive team of
collaborators across multiple sites and
of course the NIH and brain initiative
for supporting
our project and so now you'll be hearing
from Wayne Pittman another key member of
our leadership team on the challenges
and next steps in terms of programming
these devices thank you very much thank
you doctor parade Ian M Wayne Goodman
I'm a psychiatrist
and a professor and chair of psychiatry
at the Menger Department of Psychiatry
behavioral sciences at Baylor College of
Medicine and it's my pleasure to tell
you a little bit more about our study
funded by NIH brain of the brain
stimulation for depression using
directional current steering and in
develop individualized Network targeting
well here are my disclosures I'll just
give you a chance to look at that along
with doctor chef and parade Ian I'm one
of the pis on this project as described
earlier this is a complex
multidisciplinary team so I'm part of
that multidisciplinary team that
includes neurosurgeons psychiatrists
neurologists psychologists and engineers
from both Baylor UCLA Brown University
University of Pittsburgh University of
Chicago and Boston Scientific is
providing the DBS devices that we'll be
using in this study in patients with
treatment resistant depression as you've
already heard we're going to be not we
but the neurosurgeons will be implanting
DBS electrodes into brain areas
bilaterally the ventral capsule ventral
striatum as well as the sub general
cingulate cortex and as well one of the
in a very innovative aspects of this
project is also patients will be
spending approximately 10 days in the
EMU the Epilepsy Monitoring Unit in
which they will also have additional
s EEG electrodes placed in nodes within
the what has become referred to as the
depression Network and this will give us
an opportunity to learn more about that
network that forms depression at the
individual level and also be an
opportunity to test out various DBS
parameters for these two different brain
regions and then we'll all be involved
in the MU part my major role is
post-operative when I conduct the
programming of the DBS devices and what
we're hoping is during these sessions in
the EMU that we will be learning about
that patients network and a algorithm
will actually be developed that will
help dictate the programming parameters
so that it won't take months for me to
be able to optimize the programming for
that patient one of the aspects of this
study that I wanted to spend most of
this time telling you about is how we're
going to be measuring emotional state in
another NIH brain funded initiative I'm
working to develop adaptive deep brain
stimulation for obsessive-compulsive
disorder and in that study we were faced
with a challenge because we were also
recording from the brain is how do we
measure changes in mood affect anxiety
normally in in patients with psychiatric
disorders the gold standard for
assessing these different dimensions of
emotional state are to administer a
clinician rated instrument that's been
standardized but when we're looking at
changes in brain activity over very
short span of time and we're trying to
interpret those signals decode what's
happening in the brain the timeframe is
not on the same time scale as the brain
activity
so what we've identified for that study
that I just mentioned as well as this
study that we're talking about now is
the use of computer vision machine
learning in order to assess what the
emotional state of the individual based
upon their facial effect and I like to
say that that measuring tremor and
studies which are similar to this
looking at developing new technologies
of DBS for tremor whether it's in
Parkinson's disease or central tremor
it's a little bit easier in in that we
have an a more objective measure than we
do with psychiatric State but the
closest we have to the motor output the
motor output of emotional state is
affect and so that's what we we decide
to try to capitalize on I so I found a
collaborator Jeff Cohen who was a
psychologist at the University of
Pittsburgh who had developed along with
engineers at Carnegie Mellon University
a system that's referred to as automated
facial effect or recognition or fr for
short and this this platform will be
time locked in the epilepsy Monitoring
Unit with inputs recordings from the LPS
the s EEG electrodes as well as
physiology and changes in programming
that we conduct or or also in response
the tasks that we conduct in the EMU and
this FR system automatically identifies
and scores action units that is
movements of the underlying facial
muscles associated with different
effects and the here's a further
description the FR system it's based
upon approximately 40 action units have
been identified over time that map on to
discrete emotions corresponding to
movements of underlying of facial
muscles
produce these facial expressions in the
past one would have to use EMG
recordings in order to assess changes in
muscle contractions and then there was a
period of time in which a video replaced
the EMG but it required that often
graduate students and postdocs would
have to go frame-by-frame in order to
rate the changes in emotional expression
but this FR system developed by
University of Pittsburgh and Carnegie
Mellon uses machine learning computer
vision which which enables those
measurements to occur in real time in an
automated fashion and in an
old-fashioned that's quantitative in the
next video
one of the engineers who developed this
system Laszlo Jenny will be
demonstrating an important feature of
the IFR system in which the FR system
tracks facial features you'll see that
it automatically identifies eyes
eyebrows nose and mouth and then if you
look closely you will see that there's a
blue mesh superimposed over the surface
of the face and there at each point of
contact which i think is in the
neighborhood of 1,000 points the system
on the backend is measuring the
displacement or a movement underlying it
is changes in facial expression please
show the next video
so that video has demonstrated the
ability of the system to track facial
features and also to track the movement
of underlying muscle groups even though
the subject himself is moving in the
next video I'm going to show you the fr
system in action in individuals being
interviewed and what you'll see is
plotted along the screen are different
action units for example action unit 12
which is associated with the muscles
that pull up the corners of the mouth
which is one of the features associated
with smiling and you'll see as she's
speaking the action units correspond to
those different aspects of of facial
effect or action units will be
registering to the right please show the
next video
what I will be showing you in the next
video is a video clip of a patient in
the operating room this is a patient
with treatment resistant
obsessive-compulsive disorder but the
target that's been stimulated is the
same as one of the brain regions that
will be implanted in our study of
treatment resistant depression namely
the ventral capsule ventral striatum and
this particular patients case the
stimulation started on in one hemisphere
and it'll be it'll be obvious to you
when the stimulation starts she has what
we have described in the literature as a
Mirth response and I think it will be
also apparent to you about when the
stimulation is turned off as you will
see her positive effect begin to fade
and by the end she will be back to
baseline and what we've done we've taken
a video that was originally recorded in
the operating room and then use the afar
system to on top of it to demonstrate
how it can automatically and
quantitatively measure changes in in
this case the demonstration of a
positive valence effect please show the
next video
[Music]
describe what you're feeling right now
can you describe
some nice place
I think you right now
so let me summarize my segment of this
presentation on the study of the brain
stimulation using steerable currents and
treatment-resistant depression that one
of the challenges we're facing in a
psychiatric disorder is to have a way of
measuring changes in mood or other
constructs associated with depression or
other domains of depression in a way
that's objective and a way that can be
done in a fashion that we can time lock
it with the changes in DBS programming
and our recordings directly from the
brain so what I've demonstrated to you
is the use of a form of computer vision
machine learning which we refer to as
ode made facial effect recognition that
we'll be employing in the Epilepsy
Monitoring Unit as one of the outcomes
will also be using more conventional
clinical measures as well self ratings
of the patient State and those different
modalities will be combined in order for
us to have a complete picture of the
individual state both during the amnio
experience and certainly afterwards as
we attempt to improve their symptoms by
programming their devices and a
steerable current DBS leads allow more
precise stimulation to target areas
mediating therapeutic effect effects as
well as avoiding areas associated with
adverse effects
oh but the segmented leads also increase
the complexity of programming and
particularly in our study implanting
four leads targeting two different brain
areas the ventral striatum and sub genja
cingulate cortex bilaterally will add
further complexity but combining
computer vision machine learning with
network analysis during this extended
stay in the EMU may enable development
of an out
for programming in the post-operative
State you know other devices that are
also being developed offer a unique
opportunity to record in real time from
the brain during naturalistic behavior I
want to thank you for your attention and
I want to acknowledge the very large
team involved in this project from
Baylor and other institutions thank you
very much